this is a production of cornell
university
great well thank you so much for tech
for that uh that great introduction and
thank you for agreeing to let me
come work with you i wish i could be
there physically but
hopefully next semester and i'm really
looking forward to
being there in person um so yeah as what
tech said i'm going to talk to you today
about my work on um spindle assembly in
zmas
and as vatek alluded to i my background
is in yeast and when i showed up for my
postdoc
kelly said here's a seed here's soil go
for it so that was sort of my
um introduction to plant biology and i i
am still
in the process of coming to see myself
as a plant person
but in some ways it makes it all the
more exciting because there are these
things that plants do that
just weren't sort of part of my psyche
when i when i first got into chromosomes
and spindle assembly
so i'm going to tell you today a story
about
how zma's makes a lot of mistakes while
it tries to build its spindles and how
it
accounts for some of those mistakes
and my computer froze there we go so uh
we all know
that our genetic materials stored in
structures called chromosomes
and we store these chromosomes in the
nucleus of our cells
and i'm particularly interested in how
chromosomes are segregated
how do we ensure that they are divided
equally at cell division
so obviously we have our chromes located
within cells and the important machinery
here is the spindle
the machinery is made up of a series of
microtubules that forms this
network that pulls chromosomes apart so
we've you're probably all very familiar
with this sort of classical picture of
metaphase where
spindles have been built and chromosomes
are aligned at the equator
and after they've achieved this
alignment on the equator of the spindle
they're ready to be split apart and
that's the movement into
anaphase and so this is a very important
transition point in
the in any organism this is the moment
at which
you separate your chromosomes and
there's no going back whatever you end
up with in your new
cell is what you're stuck with so
um the process of segregating
chromosomes on the spindle
is similar very similar across many
different organisms
the spindle itself shown here in green
in all of the pictures
can look very different depending on the
organism everything from humans
to sea urchins to maize all use a
network of microtubules but they can
arrange this
structure in very different ways you can
see the sea urchin spindle
has a dramatic amount of astral
microtubules facing away
whereas both human and maize have most
of their microtubules
in this football structure and all of
them have their chromosomes aligned in
the middle
in metaphase so again as i mentioned
this process of building a spindle and
attaching your chromosomes to it is
critically important
um you hopefully will align your
chromosomes and split them such that you
end up with the
proper number of chromosomes after
anaphase
but sometimes this process goes wrong in
this picture shown here
you have a chromosome attaching both
sides of the chromosome
either both chromatids to one pole or
you can have other situations
where chromosomes simply aren't attached
at all and so when you make mistakes
um in attaching your chromosomes you end
up with this situation of aneuploidy
where you have
either missing or extra numbers of
chromosomes in your cells
in my graduate studies i focused heavily
on this attachment question about how
chromosomes attached to the spindle
through a structure called the
kinetochore
and then as i moved into my postdoc i've
become increasingly interested in the
spindle itself
you can have mistakes in how the spindle
is assembled so in this picture here
we have a spindle that has has too many
poles a correct spindle is bipolar
and here in this image we have a
multi-polar spindle specifically a
tri-polar with three different poles
in a situation like this which is often
common and commonly found in cancerous
cells
you're going to pull chromosomes apart
in a disorganized way and often lead to
aneuploidy
so making these kinds of mistakes is
very costly for
an organism if you do this process wrong
in mitosis which is
most of the bodies most of the cells in
our body or in plants
are mitotic cells there can be severe
consequences
but it can be even more severe in
meiosis the cell division that produces
egg and sperm
and so if we look at mitosis you can
think about if a mistake is made in a
single cell
in the body um it's a localized damage
that cell itself
may have become aneuploid which often
times induces apoptosis and the cell
dies
but if the cell doesn't properly
apoptose this can lead to
a tumor formation and ultimately cancer
which can spread throughout the body
um and obviously be very costly for the
organism
but still i would argue fairly localized
in its damage
whereas meiosis if you make a mistake in
chromosome segregation and meiosis
you now have an error in the egg or the
sperm the gamete that's produced
so in terms of the parent what this
means is a reduction in fertility
but for the offspring this can be
completely lethal
um as the entire body of the organism
the entire um
all cells within this organism now carry
that mistake
of too many or too few chromosomes and
so actually
um uh mistakes and chromosome
segregation are the leading cause of
infertility miscarriage and birth
defects
in humans so i would argue to you that
meiosis is really the most important
cell division that any sort of organism
does
um as this is going to directly uh
affect their own fertility and also the
entire
body structure of their offspring so i'm
particularly interested in how do cells
get this process right as shown in the
picture above where you properly pull
your chromosomes apart
as opposed to the bottom panel where you
have chromosomes that are being pulled
incorrectly or lagging behind on the
spindle
so specifically this um results in two
questions that i'm going to talk to you
about today
uh one how is the spindle assembled how
is that machinery built
in the first place and then two how are
chromosomes segregated
now i'm going to focus on the first
story in particular as this is new work
in my lab but i'll also tell you briefly
about what i learned in my postdoc
answering that second question as well
and i don't work in humans for many
different ethical reasons
as well as just simply logistics so
instead i focus
in the important plant system maize
and meiosis occurs obviously in both the
male and the female
parts of the plant and my work
specifically focuses on
male meiosis as these cells are easy to
get to
and we know that meiosis is critically
important in plants as well
as infertility could cause an issue in
terms
of plant reproduction offspring
so maize itself is clearly a very
agronomically important plant
meiosis is critical for breeding and
also crop yield so beyond
questions of human health these
questions are equally important in
plants
and part of the reason i was really
drawn to maize as a model system
is the ability to collect so many
meiotic cells
and this is particularly important in my
lab where i work with undergraduates
as these kinds of dissections and
microsurgeries are
more easily done in a plant system than
in in an animal system
another great uh benefit to maize is
that we have
a lot of genetic and genomic tools
including fluorescently labeled
transgenic lines and so this has allowed
me to develop a live imaging system
where we can image much in the way that
animal systems have been imaged we can
image
how spindles assemble and how
chromosomes pull apart um
live and measure the dynamics of the
process and so one really exciting thing
for me when i began my postdoc was that
while there had been meiotic imaging in
terms of chromosome dynamics and how
chromosomes move
um the spindles themselves had never
been imaged in any plant in meiosis
certainly there's a lot of great mitotic
imaging work done
in various different parts of mitotic
tissues in a plant but i was
excited to look at meiotic spindles in
particular
so um how i do this is i harvest
the tassel out of an immature maize
plant uh
slice open slice open the plant and
remove the immature tassel
and on the tassel are florets and inside
of the florets are anthers and this is
where the male meiotic
cells are located so i dissect out the
anther
i cut off the top and then i very gently
squeeze out the meiotic cells you can
see them
those little round gray balls that are
oozing out
and once i've gotten them extruded from
the anther
i pipet them up very gently and
put them in onto a cover slide for
imaging
so i'm going to show you now a series of
movies um
that are focused on um how the spindle
assembles so
most of my movies begin in prophase one
and what you will see
are green labeled microtubules
specifically
it was a cfp beta tubulin fusion
courtesy of ann sylvester in her group
she and her collaborators made a series
of fluorescently tagged
maize lines that have been extremely
helpful in my imaging system and so i
was able to use her beta tubulin fusion
so what you'll see in these movies
are the nuclear envelopes still intact
and microtubules
having sort of a hairy network structure
around the nuclear
envelope that nuclear envelope is going
to collapse and then
in that location a spindle is going to
assemble
here showing you the final metaphase
spindle before it moves into
actual pulling chromosomes apart in
anaphase
i also have some meiosis ii movies as
well where it looks very similar except
that
meiosis one has completed and built a
cell wall between
these two cells and so now you have
nuclear envelopes that
collapse and assemble spindles in both
halves of
um of that cell space
and then later in my talk i will tell
you a little bit about chromosome
segregation and the only difference here
now is that chromosomes are labeled and
shown in pink they are particularly
labeled with
cyto-12 dna stain and they i've marked
them as these
pink masses in my movies
so um to the first question about how is
the spindle assembled
so here is um a movie that i want to
show you of two meiosis one
cells you can see in both of them the
nuclear envelope is intact and the
microtubules are that sort of
mesh network around them on the outside
and so if i play the movie what you'll
see is a nuclear envelope breaks down
all of the microtubule structure
collapses into that space
and a bipolar spindle is built out of it
i'll play that again
there's the collapse the assembly of the
bipolar spindle and then actually here
is the movement into anaphase and then
this structure appearing right here
is the fragmoplast and so
um we can collect movies both in meiosis
1 and meiosis 2.
so the cell on the right is a meiosis 1
cell whereas the
cell on the left is two different
meiosis one cells with
the cell wall that now separates them
and again the process is very similar in
breakdown of the nuclear envelope
and then an assembly of this bipolar
spindle that fills most of the cell
volume
and in this movie it didn't i don't
further proceed into anaphase we stop
here at these bipolar spindles
so what we've learned from gathering
these images of spindle assembly is that
there are several steps in the process
and we've been measuring the dynamics of
the process
so like i mentioned what happens first
is the nuclear envelope breaks down
and all of the microtubules collapse
into this nuclear space and so that
process of nuclear envelope breakdown
takes about eight minutes
on average and then going from this
collapsed spindle um sort of massive
chromosomes into the bipolar structure
what i show in this middle panel is what
i would now call a bipolar spindle
and then in the last step it sharpens
the poles to be on these very tight
points
spindle focusing so that whole process
um
from collapse to bipolar takes about 29
minutes on average
if we look just at the spindle focusing
component where it goes from that sort
of
more broad spindle which actually is
more similar to a mitotic mace spindle
mitotic mace spindles do not have those
sharp focus pulls
so the focusing step takes about 16
minutes
and we know actually that stuff is very
critical there
is a classical maze mutant called dv1
that lacks the kinesin to help do this
focusing um and so it's
uh spindle poles stay splayed like this
and we know that this
um uh this mutant has defects in
chromosome segregation
and we actually have imaged this mutant
live and we can see how the chromosomes
get pulled
incorrectly without being transferred to
a very specific spot
by a focused pole so if you look at the
process
in total from nuclear envelope breakdown
to the collapse into the inner space
creation of the bipolar spindle and then
sharpening focusing of the poles
this whole process takes about 35
minutes
from start to fully formed bipolar
spindle
and what i found actually is that there
are some differences in the dynamics
between meiosis one and meiosis
ii and so in particular um meiosis
one seems to take a little longer it is
statistically significant it takes about
seven more minutes on average than
meiosis ii
um so in yellow you'll see or orangish
color you'll see a
meiosis ii distribution where is in
blue you see meiosis one distribution um
and so there does seem to be this shift
in terms of
the distribution of time it takes
meiosis one
spindles to assemble
so um what we know
about meiosis one versus two i'm looking
through all of the videos here is that
the breakdown process
of the envelope does not appear to be
any different there's no timing
no difference in timing no it doesn't
there doesn't seem to be any structural
differences
and so the difference comes from the
actual spindle assembly component
it's part itself that moment of collapse
um to full full assembly and so here's
the
here's the um distribution plot of uh
just that sort of middle part of the
process from collapse to bipolar spindle
and um again if we look at the averages
here
meiosis 1 averages about 31 minutes
whereas meiosis 2 averages
about 25 minutes and again this is
statistically significant
the um the focusing on the polls as well
doesn't seem to show any difference in
terms of the timing
or process so all the difference lies in
this
actual assembly of the microtubules into
the correct bipolar form
so um i started thinking about this a
bit and i
curious why that process is slower in
meiosis one
my first thought was you know are
meiosis ii spindle smaller
or you know as measured by a proxy of
length um
what we know is that the spindle length
is the same there's no statistical
difference in terms of its length
in terms of chromosome content we know
at this point that homologous
chromosomes have been separated
but sister chromatids are still paired
so in that sense there are still the
same number of connection points to the
spindle so in theory
there would be just as many kinetochore
microtubules attaching but that's
certainly something i'm interested in
looking
into in terms of the content of
microtubules and these spindles are
there
are there um less uh required components
to build at this point
one area that i'm interested as well and
following up in
is is the difference due to cellular
volume so
as you can see from just this picture
right here meiosis
ii cells are much smaller they're about
on average half the volume
so i'm going to do a closer measurement
of cell volume in these and
look to see if there's a correlation
between cell volume
and assembly time because there is a
little bit of variation in terms of size
of meiosis 1 and meiosis 2 cells
so my idea or thought is that perhaps in
this smaller volume
um you get a higher concentration of
components um there's simply
a higher concentration of things that
assemble the spindle the
tubulin components of them themselves
and so there's less space in which for
them to
need to find one another to assemble the
spindle
now if you're watching closely in my
movies here what you might have seen
is this time point right here which i
was saying
is the collapsed point at where the
nuclear envelope is fully broken down
the microtubules exist now in that space
that was the nuclear um
the nucleus and actually if i add in
another time point for you here i wasn't
showing this one before
but what you see is actually a tripolar
spindle
so later on we ultimately do achieve a
bipolar spindle but
during the process of building the
spindle it is
tripolar for a period of time um
and so in order to uh correctly pull
chromosomes apart
as i mentioned before that needs to be
corrected if we went through anaphase at
this point with three poles
you get chromosomes being pulled
unequally
and not allowing chromosomes to be
separated into two volumes
and like i said that can obviously
result in aneuplating
and like i said correction did occur in
this particular cell it did go from
tripolar to bipolar
also in that first movie i showed you
there was another instance of a tripolar
the top cell here which you can see in
panel e
again the movies i collect here i'm
collecting data in three-dimensional
space
and so what i've been showing you here
are um z dimensional collapses but if
you do look through all layers of the
planes you can see more sharply
more more focused that there are three
poles um so in panel e is probably
e d or e are probably the best
representation of that and then moving
from panel e to f there is this
correction
into a bipolar spindle
um this is one movie in particular where
i thought the correction was very
pronounced so i'd like to show you
this one a spindle has formed tripolar
designated here with the
white arrows
and if we watch that tripolar shape has
to collapse two of the poles
and then ultimately end up bipolar so
let's play that again
for you so you can see that these two
bottom poles
collapse into one and fold up together
so um by analyzing all of our data what
we have found is actually the majority
of the time
cells initiate an incorrect number of
poles on their spindles so actually
tripolar
is the most common spindle structure so
what i mean by initiating correctly is
that upon breakdown of the nuclear
envelope
the first structure that forms is
actually tripolar
most of the time and then has to correct
into a bipolar form and so if we add
together all of the different incorrect
forms so in addition to tripolar we also
sometimes find these multipolar spindles
where there are four
or more poles and sometimes the the
it simply is too chaotic to really
assign so we call that unorganized where
there just seemed to be
um too much lack of organization to
initially see either a bipolar
or some sort of other multipolar spindle
so if we add together our tripolar
multipolar and unorganized spindles
um that gives us 61 of the time spindles
actually form
incorrectly and then need to actively
correct into bipolar
and what we found is that 63 of the time
um those incorrectly formed spindles do
correct so it's certainly not anywhere
near 100 um
but the majority do correct and move on
without consequence
for uh cells that that do correct that
correction time
takes about 10 to 15 minutes
before they proceed to anaphase
and so as you can imagine if you've
built a spindle incorrectly and then you
need to take
that additional 10 to 15 minutes to
correct it
the full assembly process in these cells
that initiate incorrectly is longer
on average so if you initiate
incorrectly
it takes an additional seven minutes or
so to get all the way to a correct
spindle
um one thing you may notice here is that
that sort of seven minute average there
doesn't equate to the 10 to 15 minutes i
just said
so there does seem to be i'm still
quantifying but
um in cells that initiate correctly once
they reach a correct
metaphase spindle there is a period of
weight
or hold time before you move from
metaphase to anaphase
and what it seems to be is that in cells
that initiate incorrectly
um they sort of make up a little bit of
time during that hold
so um i think that they they don't hold
and metaphase quite as long
they correct into a bipolar spindle and
move a little more quickly into anaphase
um than cells are initiated correctly
and the spindle correction time is
also dependent on the type of meiosis
meiosis one versus two
um so what i found is that meiosis two
spindles correct faster than meiosis one
cells
um and this also um plays right along
with the fact that
it looked like meiosis two spindles
build um assemble faster in general like
we said before and again that could be
back to that
that same idea of a more constrained
volume in which you're operating so your
um your regulatory components and your
building blocks are more easily
accessible perhaps
and if when you look at this
distribution plot here um you
may be drawn to this little plot out
here that seems to be a dramatic outlier
in terms of the amount of time
it took this particular cell to correct
everything else is fairly tightly
distributed
around this you know 15 minute mark and
so we had this one cell that
took 45 minutes to correct so i was
curious
what was going on in that particular
cell
um and what i found is actually in this
particular cell
two completely bipolar spindles formed
as you look through the panels here in
this
top right hand panel we have two fully
formed bipolar spindles
and then starting this bottom panel they
have to now merge themselves into a
single bipolar spindle
and then the last two panels they go
through anaphase
so this was really exciting um because
coming from the animal world
there's been a lot of in vitro studies
of chromosome and spindle dynamics
rebecca heel is an excellent chromosome
spindle biologist who's
had done a lot of imaging on chromosomes
being sort of this hub for spindle
assembly and how spindles will
assemble around any chromosome mass so
should your masses of chromosomes be
further apart you can build separate
independent spindles
um and all of her work had been done in
vitro and obviously in an animal system
so i was really excited when we found
this movie as it's sort of this real
imbibo
evidence this that this ability does
exist in cells to
merge two totally independent spindles
um correctly formed bipolar spindles
that should be
um attaching their chromosomes correctly
it's able to recognize this and now
merge the two spindles into a single one
before moving into anaphase
so why so many mistakes
so one important point here is that
plant spindles lack centrosomes or the
organizing spindle
or the organizing center the hub from
which microtubules can nucleate out
animal mitotic cells have these kinds of
organizing centers
but animal meiotic systems also lack
centrosomes
so in these types of cells
all plant cells or female meiotic cells
and obviously certainly
plant meiotic cells you have to build a
spindle without those organizing
discrete organizing centers so these
sorts of asymtrosomal spindles as we
call them
have to regulate their own assembly
through some sort of self-organization
process
so in this top panel you see those
centrioles those organizing centers that
nucleate out microtubules and attach to
chromosomes whereas in the bottom panel
acetosomal spindles
have this network this hub of
microtubules that are nucleating around
chromosomes and then
build out to a bipolar shape
so we're really interested in this
process then how is that a centrosomal
process being regulated in our system
and we know that there are evidence for
multiple different pathways the two
primary ones
being the rand gtp pathway so this is
the process by which
ran which is also involved in nuclear
import helps deposit
spindle assembly factors in your
chromosomes and another system
or another pathway called the cpc or
chromosome passenger complex pathway
again is a gradient that's focused near
chromosomes
near their centromeres and the two main
players in both of these
in the rand gtp pathway a series of
proteins but one that i'm particularly
focused on
the rand gap protein which helps convert
ran gdp to the gtp form and in order to
allow the deposition
of these components and the cpc pathway
is aurora b um and
rorby has many different roles um in
spindle assembly and attachment of
chromosomes and so i'm particularly
intrigued
as this is sort of a new role that's
been found for rorby
in the initial assembly of the spindle
itself rather than just a correction or
checking mechanism
after the fact after the spindle's been
created
so um we are following up in my lab by
looking at these two different pathways
so the images i'm going to show you here
are actually
fixed immunostained images so i
apologize my color scheme changes at
this point so we now have
microtubules stained in red and
chromosomes
in blue here so we've been working on
inhibiting these potential pathways
using drugs
so we are targeting aurora b using
hesperidin which has been demonstrated
to target specifically aurora bee
in mitotic plant cells as well as animal
systems
and this inhibition does appear to be
specific to aurora b and other systems
so we
feel fairly confident using this as a
target
or as a um as a small molecule
inhibitor for rb we are also inhibiting
rand gtp using importazone
and um just some representative images
um
here for you there do seem to be some
very
striking morphology defects here you can
see in aurora b
we have a very distinct tripolar spindle
and here on the right we have what i
would call sort of a disorganized
spindle
where we don't have distinct pulls but
clearly this is an incorrect spindle
over here in this picture of inhibition
of ran
we have poles that don't look fully
focused and we don't have a nice
congression
of chromosomes on the equator
and another component that we're
actually looking into are the kinesins
involved in building the spindle as i
mentioned before
dv1 which is a kinesin 14
is very involved in building the spindle
so we are using a particular inhibitor
that
affects eg eg5 kinesin and we are
finding some very dramatic effects
of knocking down that kinesin as well
so um as you i'm sure know you know drug
inhibition can have some off-target
consequences and it's not quite as clean
or direct
um as knockouts and knockdowns so this
was sort of our pilot study um and now
that we're getting some initial
um promising phenotypes we are currently
creating some
rnai knockdown lines i hesitate to use
crispr on these just because these
components probably are
essential so we are creating rni lines
to hopefully drop
expression level
so um one another interesting thing
we've seen here too
is that um inhibiting particularly the
rand gtp pathway
will lead to a block in cell cycle
and so what this means is that it
suggests that there is an active
checkpoint that's making sure this
process is going correctly
so if here's what um the different parts
of the cycle look like we start off at
prophase
condense our chromosomes and
prometaphase
align them in metaphase and then pull
them apart in anaphase
to the phase and cytokinesis um i
apologize in these images i don't have
spindles marked but those are
chromosomes that you're seeing in white
where they condense in a line
in metaphase and then pull apart an
anaphase when we look
um in cells that have been treated
particularly with in cortisol we're
still working on the hisperidin
the aurora b treatments but when we
um not when we affect the rand gtp
pathway
what we see in red here those are the
cells that have been treated with
um the rand gap
small molecule is we see an accumulation
of cells in prometaphase
where normally under control situations
you have a fair number of cells in pro
prophase and then they cycle quickly
through prometaphase
metaphase anaphase as they build their
spindles and are able to proceed
but in in cortisol we get this large
block of cells that are holding up
prometaphase most likely because they
are unable to build their spindles and
therefore
not move forward in the process which
suggests there is an
active spindle assembly a checkpoint
something is looking and making sure
this process is working
and saying no you're not ready to
proceed
we also have here shown in blue taxol
which is a known microtubule
depolymerizer and sort of our control in
this
in this situation
so one thing that i'm interested in
following up on um is
a looking more closely at this spindle
assembly checkpoint
um so mad2 is a protein that is one of
the critical
components of the spindle checkpoint so
i believe matt2 is important in this
process here in terms of monitoring
the assembly of the spindle and then the
passage allowing it to move forward into
the metaphase anaphase transition
and so what you see in these two panels
down here in b and d is
mad 2 is labeled in red and
in kelly daw's lab back in 1999 they
identified maize mad 2
and they showed that it does localize
on kinetochores on that attachment point
of chromosomes to the spindle
it localizes there when things are not
correct and then once you build a
correct
spindle you can see in that panel d
there the signal goes away it's no
longer localizing
which suggests now that the spindle
checkpoint is satisfied and is going to
allow cells to progress
so um that's part of what i'd like to do
in votec's lab
is um thanks to um members of his lab
kasia in particular
is making a matthew m cherry um
transgenic line for me in maze
and when i can come to campus i'd like
to do some
live live imaging of mad2 on the
kinetochores during this whole spindle
assembly process
and study the dynamics of how is it
reacting to these kinds of mistakes and
is it is it localizing on those
kinetochores when there are
mistakes and then disappearing when it's
resolved these images here in b and d
are all fixed images and i think we need
a finer level
of detail and to look at the dynamic
process to really understand what's
happening
so thanks so much to the paulowski lab
for hosting me and i can't wait to get
there in person
so um with just the last little bit i'm
going to tell you very briefly
about the second part of this process
once you've built your spindle and
corrected it and hopefully is now
bipolar
um how do you actually pull chromosomes
apart and this is a story
that i worked on in my postdoc but i
want to tell you about just one brief
interesting thing that came out of it
so um in these particular movies um i
again microtubules are labeled in green
but now you'll be able to see
chromosomes which are labeled pink uh
due to a cyto-12 dna stain
and again you have meiosis one and
meiosis two cells
so um meiosis one here on the left
we are starting with a metaphase spindle
um so the spindle has been built
correctly into a bipolar shape
and chromosomes are aligned on the
equator
and there you see the chromosomes
pulling apart anaphase the spindle
breaking down
let's get that play again
there we go um and that is the
fragmaplast then that is appearing
afterwards
there it is right there um likewise in
meiosis
ii we have the two spindles side by side
in the resulting cells for meiosis one
and similarly they pull apart in that
metaphase anaphase transition
and then build a phragmoplast out of the
microtubule remnants in the center
of the cell so
in these studies what we did was we
honed in particularly on the chromosomes
and tracked their motion on the spindle
so what you see here are just
chromosomes the spindle is no longer in
this image
and what will happen is this mass of
chromosomes in the middle is going to be
pulled apart
and what we did was track the movement
of that chromosome mass during anaphase
to investigate the dynamics so again
just backing up you'll see
a blue line appearing that is our
tracking in three dimensional space
of the chromosome mass and there it goes
so um like i said we had our system that
we're looking at in three dimensions and
we could hone in on that chromosome and
track it as it moved through all the
frames of the movie and specifically
again focusing just on the chromosomes
in this question
um and how they moved and this allowed
us
as i said to track them in
three-dimensional space and look at
things like
how far do they move how fast do they
move
where within the cell are they
positioned and how often do they make
mistakes
and so what we found was that actually
surprisingly they made very
few mistakes so um most of the time
uh the dramatic most of the time um
there was a very uniform anaphase in
terms of the pulling apart of
chromosomes
there was a few instances of slow moving
chromosomes
where chromosomes are lagging behind the
main mast which you can see in this
panel
on the bottom but eventually that was
resolved and the slow-moving chromosomes
did catch up with the rest of the mass
we had very few instances of lagging
chromosomes
which i defined as chromosomes that
stayed behind on the antiphrase bridge
they lagged behind and they never fully
caught up with the main mass of
chromosomes as you can see in this last
panel they continue to sort of be
stretched out
and never fully um resolved
but one particular thing really popped
out at us as we were watching these
movies um
in most if not all
anaphase you see a very symmetric
division
of chromosomes on the spindle when i say
most if not all i mean other systems
a lot of different movies of metaphase
to anaphase transition you can watch in
many different species and many
different cell types
and there are only a few exceptions to
this example
but we found something very very
dramatic
in many many of our cells we actually
saw
what we called asymmetric movement of
chromosomes on the spindle
so if this is a symmetric movement where
the chromosomes line up at the equator
they pull apart equal distances away
from that equator
and we know that that movement is
powered by forces generated within the
spindle that apply equally on both
masses of chromosomes
so we saw this very dramatic asymmetric
movement where
one side one mass of the chromosomes
moved much further on the spindle than
the other
mass of chromosomes and this is very
very odd um
it actually never been seen before in
this type of
myotic system and the only example i
could find
were some very specific cases
where there are other components
involved and usually some sort of trauma
or incident
involved that causes this kind of
movement and the interesting thing about
all of my movies that i've shown you
here today is these are all wild type
dynamics these are things we didn't
really realize cells were doing because
we had never taken that fine of a look
and so um down in this bottom panel you
can see an example of this asymmetric
movement
so i've marked the chromosome movement
paths in two different colors
in the bottom you'll see one mass of
chromosomes with the blue line
that is the mass of chromosomes that
move very far on the spindle
and the other mass of chromosomes marked
with that little orange trail
that's the dis that's the path that this
other mass of chromosomes took and it's
significantly shorter than the other
mass
so if we measure these chromosome
movements
um and in my scheme here you will see
the mass of chromosomes that move
further is labeled in blue so i call
that mass a
the mass of chromosomes that move not as
far in the spindle as mass b
shown in orange and it is statistically
significant over time
these chromosomes do move much further
on the spindle than b
so it's not just in a few cells and it's
not just something temporary it is
a movement that is then sustained
i won't show you the data today but they
are actually moving faster as well in
the spindle so they both reached their
final dusting
destinations at about the same time
because a is moving much faster than b
and so we were very curious about um
what is causing this asymmetry of
movement
and even to this day we're still very
curious about um how in terms of forced
generation this is able to happen
so uh one of the questions we asked was
um perhaps what's happening
is that the chromosomes um this is
happening in cells where the chromosomes
are not exactly lined up on the equator
perhaps the mass of chromosomes are
offset a little bit
so in movies where there are asymmetric
divisions perhaps the chromosomes are
off
offset from the center of the spindle
and we can measure that offset
denoted here as delta chromosome spindle
so
an offset distance from from the equator
so we looked in cells that were
very symmetric in their division and
cells that were very asymmetric in their
division
and what we found really is that there
was no difference in terms of the
chromosome location on the spindle so no
there was no
offset of chromosomes on the equator to
explain this kind of movement
and next what we looked at was um
placement of
the spindle within the cell itself um
the cell you can imagine we are going to
do a division here to create um
two cells and we would like that to be a
very equal division such that the two
resulting cells end up with equal
cellular volume because we're going to
go then into meiosis 2 and again we'd
want to have an equal distribution of
cell volume so perhaps what's going on
here
is that maybe the spindle is offset from
where you would want it
you would would you would want this
spindle in the middle of the cell
so that you pull your chromosomes into
equal volumes and then build your
new cell wall in the middle
and indeed what we did is we looked at
the symmetric and asymmetric divisions
and in these cases the spindles were
more offset closer to the edge of the
cell
in the asymmetric asymmetric divisions
and i don't have time to show you all
the data today
but what we found is that the mass of
chromosomes chromosome mass a that moves
much further on the spindle
is moving into the larger cell volume
so yes it does seem to be that
chromosomes are
moving more on the side of the spindle
that needs to go further to get into an
equal cell volume
and the last kind of interesting thing
that i want to show you here
something that kind of caught our
attention was i don't have very many
movies of these
but um every once in a while i will see
an instance where
the spindle fails completely and is not
able to pull chromosomes apart and i'll
just show you what happens here in this
one particular cell
where we have built a spindle
chromosomes are lined up in the middle
in metaphase
and here's what happens
so what you see is their chromosomes are
lined up in metaphase but the spindle
fails and so the chromosomes just start
floating away
but then the cell initiates formation of
the fragment plast even despite this
issue and in these middle panes here you
can see the fragment plus starting to
form
here and it actually actually displaces
and pushes the chromosomes
out of the way and separates them into
the two masses
so i found this very intriguing
certainly this would be a very bad way
to segregate your chromosomes as there's
no
um directing which chromosomes go which
way but it is
curious and intriguing to see if this
could perhaps be
sort of a lastish ditch effort if all
else fails is this your sort of last
chance to at least separate your
chromosomes in some mechanism
such that perhaps you still have a
chance at fertility
so um just to recap what i've told you
guys about today
um what we see while watching wild-type
maze meiosis is that there are a lot of
mistakes in this process
um the the process of assembling a
spindle is very error-prone
um in many of the cases spindles
initiate a tripolar spindle
that has to be corrected before cells
can move into anaphase otherwise they
will have this mis-segregation event of
their chromosomes
and we're investigating now sort of the
acentrosomal pathways that regulate that
spindle assembly now that we've got a
handle on the dynamics
we'd like to track down now the pathway
is important for that and we do have
some very good evidence
of two or three different pathways
involved in this process
and also i'm looking at the role then of
the checkpoint as well what is the
checking mechanism that not only makes
sure
that spindle is formed and chromosomes
are correctly on the spindle
but also the whole process is going
correctly and i have some preliminary
evidence that mad2 that protein that i'm
interested in studying
is involved in the initial building of
the spindle as well not just a final
checkpoint
um and then in the last part of the
story i told you about this strange
asymmetric movement of chromosomes that
we observed
this seems to be a corrective mechanism
a way to get
your chromosomes into equal volume so
the spindle will pull chromosomes
further on the side that needs to travel
further in cell volume in order to
place these masses equally within the
cell volume
and then lastly i um this kind of
interesting idea
of the fragment class perhaps is a
mechanism of separating your chromosomes
and certainly not a good
choice on how to separate your
chromosomes but if all
spells is this at least a way to
separate them and allow you to move
forward in the cell cycle
into meiosis ii and beyond
so with that i just want to say thank
you to everybody that's
been involved in this project
particularly my students at hamilton
like votech said i've been here uh three
years this is now my fourth year
they've had a bunch of excellent
students that have
collected this data and analyzed this
data one student in particular jody here
with her
maize plant she did a lot of the
analysis in this work
current students in my lab particularly
shelby mcvay has done a lot of the work
on this project
and then i'd like to say thank you to
votec and also kasia for making my
mad2m cherry line and the whole lab for
letting me join in on your
your zoom meetings and hopefully i will
get to meet you all in person next
semester
and also thank you to kelly my postdoc
advisor who i continue to collaborate
with
as well as the national science
foundation for funding much of this work
and with that i'd turn it over to
questions
thank you natalie that was very
informative
any questions
i'd like to ask a question
um i was curious that the number of
tripolar spindles was is at the onset
was greater than
the number of bipolar spindles yeah and
i wonder
if it has anything to do with the um
technique you use to get beautiful
movies unbelievably
beautiful but um
do you see as many people that have done
sectioning of anthers
do they see the proportion of bipolar
tripoli spindles that you've seen
yeah that's a it's a really good
question um and certainly uh when we
were writing up our our first story well
and actually the second story i told
today about the asymmetric movement of
chromosomes on the spindle that was a
major concern of our reviewers
was you know it's something about the
treatment of the cells causing this kind
of movement
and so we looked
at our movies and um you know one of our
concerns was
like simply are we squishing the cells
are we compressing them or damaging them
in some way that's causing these kinds
of phenotypes
and so we've modeled the cell volume and
it doesn't seem to be compressed in any
way
um certainly there is always a question
about
um you know removing from them from the
context of their
um their tissue have we done something
um
it is hard to compare this to fixed
datum because that moment in time where
it's tripoli to bipolar is about 10
minutes
and so um i've done a lot of fixed work
but it's
very hard to catch them in that 10
minute time to see
are there a large proportion of triple
or spindles and certainly there are many
mutants out there
that have um a predominance of tripolar
spindles
and um that could be an instance perhaps
then
that shows yes tripolar spindles do
happen at a pretty high frequency and
these mutants that are clearly involved
in that corrective pathway
um so that's actually something i want
to follow up on the future is now moving
this live imaging system
into um those mutant backgrounds
um but um we you know
we don't think that we are creating that
that tripolar um
phenotype with our system but that's
actually another thing that i'd like to
do with vertex group as well
um with the multi-photon imaging we can
stay inside of the anther and we don't
have to do the extruding process of the
myotic cells out
my setup doesn't have the ability to go
quite so deep into tissue so i have to
get the cells out of their anther
context but i would be very curious to
look at that and to
to confirm that this is not something
that we're inducing
with our methods although we seem to
have evidence that suggests that's not
the case
that would be a beautiful way to test
that can you tell us
a little bit how you prepare how you put
the cells on the cover slips and
yeah yeah absolutely so i extrude them
from their um
isolate the anthers cut off fans extrude
them out um
and then i pipet them onto a cover slide
with sufficient
liquid volume that the cells are not
compressed there is
about um 80 to 100 microns spacing
between my coverslip
and the slide whereas the modex cells
themselves are about
40 45 microns in diameter so
um the distance from the cover slip to
the slide is a larger volume in which
the
cells have to exist and i also affix
them to
the cover slip to assist with imaging um
using um
poly lysine so that they don't float
away on me um and i let them sort of
settle gently out of the cover slip and
then
in my movie i did it really fast but
then put them onto the slide for imaging
um and i take z slices um
i'm trying to remember what my steps
were i think my steps were
10 micron steps um so i can get the
whole cell volume
and make sure that i have not like
compressed it that is still around
um brown cell volume
it's a round cell volume um
yep taking into consideration the
difference in the axial
resolution yeah i actually have movies
sorry sorry go ahead yeah so um
you you must not see a round cell volume
so um you're right so resolution in z is
obviously much worse
um uh so i do have movies where my
spindle is oriented through the z plane
um and so i actually tend to focus my
analyses where i have
um uh it laying in x y rather than in z
um because it's uh yeah the resolution
is just really not as good the images
are not nearly as sharp
so um you can you can find spindles
oriented this way in terms of my imaging
well thanks it's beautiful beautiful
work thank you thank you
and natalie you have a question
in the great which i can read if you
have
problems um it says let's see is there
any functional significance to the
spindle
focus shape difference between meiosis
and mitosis um yeah great question um is
there
variation in mitotic spindle morphology
among cell types
um yeah so that is actually something
i'm really interested in
um so like i said the maize
mitotic spindle is more of a barrel
shape it does not have nice focused
pulls
i've been curious since i first joined
kelly's lab about why that is and um
you know i don't have a good answer to
that right now
um i think that you know there are
clearly differences in mitotic versus
meiotic assembly
um in mitotic assembly there's a
preprophase ban
that exists perpendicular to uh the
spindle axis that gets formed
the preprophase band doesn't exist in
meiosis and so how do you orient
positioning without
a pre-prophase ban is very interesting
and so clearly
the some of the machinery and process is
different
i have a colleague carolyn rasmussen
at uc riverside she focuses on mitotic
imaging and she and i have chatted
um quite a bit about this process um and
so
we would like to look at the differences
here you know what are the players
why is it different she focuses on
tangled
and its involvement and positioning
of the uh the spindle axis and
positioning the new cell wall and so
we'd like to take a look at tangled in
meiosis because that has not been done
yet
but in terms of the focusing of the
poles and mitosis
versus meiosis you know it could be
simply um
you know my meiotically expressed
kinesins that are not present in mitotic
or it could be you know um you know just
differences in terms of the reality of
cell volume or cell shape you know brick
versus round but
um yeah we don't know right now and it's
something that that i'm really
interested in
thanks yeah so natalie i have a question
too if i may so yeah um this is about
the transition
of that
[Music]
round to a nuclei
tubulin uh mass or band into
into the spindle so uh earlier
in in prop phase like in zygote and
packaging
uh um there's actually quite a bit of
like circum nuclear cytoskeleton
that also includes actin so is this
cytoskeleton we're used for the spindle
and if yes what happens to the actin
do you know anything about that that is
a really interesting question
um i really don't know much about actin
um in terms of this process um
their um
and sylvester has so there is a
potential dynein
um in maize that could be involved with
um
dynein being a motor on actin that could
be involved with pushing and pulling
and in other systems actin often helps
align
the spindle in the volume um there is a
role for
for um you know nudging the spindle
around using actin as well as
um you know the the astral microtubules
that position
outwards so um dynein or sorry yeah
i was thinking the dynein on the astral
microtubules sorry yeah so um
in terms of the the the actin i don't
know and it's not something i've looked
into yet um
but certainly it could be very
worthwhile
given that um uh you know its presence
in the cell
um yeah
yeah i just haven't investigated it much
but um but the dining um this is what i
was thinking of the
the role of dining on astro microtubules
can can help with positioning um and so
uh we do have a fluorescence labeled
dining um that i want to see
if it's involved with astro microtubules
at all so it wasn't
thought that maze meiotic spindles have
very many of them in my movies you see
these really clear points but you don't
see much splaying out from there
but we know that there are a few of them
i do have a few movies where
um there are eight it seems like a
couple of astral microtubules and they
actually kind of rotate the spindle
around
uh in the cell volume so that was kind
of a surprising movie that we found as
well um because
we didn't think there were very many of
them if
if any at all so um yeah that's another
thing i'd like to look into as well
okay thank you any more
questions
okay so if that's the case
thank you natalie again uh it was a
beautiful seminar
and thank you all for
your attention thank you so much for
having me i really appreciate being able
to uh
to talk to you all today okay great
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu